do you know what a Harlequin is a
Harlequin well it's a mute character and
traditional pantomime they typically
have like a mask and a diamond pattern
costume some kind or in a different
definition that's less used you know
it's like a small duck kind of inhabit
fast flowing streams in the Arctic you
know they have grey and blue plumage I
was I was trying to do an opening bit by
quoting the movie first and you just
totally cut me off too I wasn't even
listening to what the actual definition
of a Harlequin is I was trying to just
quote the movie to make the interval
it's a mute character and traditional
pantomime birds of prey paper and the
fantabulous emancipation of one Harley
Quinn so I know a lot of people were
concerned because this was a movie or
the review embargo they said they can't
put any official reviews out til the day
before the movie is released and usually
that is a terrible warning sign I still
held out faith if you watched any of our
countless trailer reactions for this
film I was like you know what I know a
lot of people are not super hyped about
this but I have a lot of faith in it I'm
not just saying it to defend my own
anticipation ego there's been plenty of
times where I'm like you know what I was
wrong everything I had faith in I was
totally wrong about I'm gonna be blunt I
loved the hell movie if you follow me on
Twitter like that's all I said I I
really had a great time I thought it was
a total blast do I have like a couple of
little issues here and there sure we'll
go into them they're very minor but for
the most part I thought this was a
fantabulous time yeah likewise I had a
great time I had a blast and a half yeah
it was just as colourful and bonkers
filled with personality as I hoped it
would be also yeah I mean John and I are
wearing these clothes and I wanted to
shout these guys out right away I mean
if you've been on the internet for any
length of time you know roosterteeth
you've seen red vs. blue they have a
whole buttload of other content and they
send this this like giant ass box of
stuff they're getting into merch people
so roll that photo shoot John and I did
[Music]
[Music]
so we got early access to these clothes
keep your eye on roosterteeth
that's right build a bit of a YouTube
career in roosterteeth mind notice you
Thank You roosterteeth for sending this
over you'll see us wearing these clothes
a lot throughout the remainder of this
channel that's for sure alright so the
plot for this movie is not exactly all
that difficult to follow it's actually a
really simple plot what makes it special
and unique is really its execution after
watching the movie I get why they might
have had some difficulty conveying what
the movies actually about because it's
kind of about like a couple of things
going on all at once but really it's
simple Harley Quinn has broken up with
the Joker she's had a lot of immunity in
the criminal underworld because she is
the girlfriend to the Joker now that she
is on her own there's a lot of people
after her now that's communicated in the
trailer there's also this other plot the
main villains they're all looking for a
specific diamond right and then somehow
from the birds of prey characters Harley
Quinn Cassandra Cain they're all getting
involved and it's all about the diamond
and they're all trying to avoid being
eliminated by black masks Roman seoane
is played by Ewan McGregor so for
starters I think the whole cast in this
movie is wonderful this really is more
Harley Quinn's movie than anyone else's
with that being said one of my concerns
was will the birds of prey shine in this
film and I thought the whole ensemble
was great Harley Quinn is most certainly
the lead and she is hilarious in this
movie there I mean cracking up from
beginning to end she's kind of like
taking on a bit of a what I can only
describe as a Jack Sparrow like role you
know where there's a lot of like quirky
coincidental things that go on with her
there's Jack Sparrow and pirates one
there's Jack Sparrow in the last pirates
movie and this is like pirates one Jack
Sparrow it's still good it's still great
action scenes are wonderful and the
evolution of her character is great so
much of the emotional depth provided by
her but the comedic Sensibility she
provides are so on point I loved her in
it it's just a character it seems like
she was born to play you know she's so
natural and it seems like she's having
so much fun
but not too much fun to the point where
it's taking away from the role like it
really does seem like she's a hundred
percent invested in Harlequin easily
probably the equal performer or second
greatest performer in the film is Eva
McGregor as black mask and I gotta say
that if you are a major black masks fan
I can see how this performance could
upset you because it's definitely a lot
more eccentric quirky childish little
flamboyant I kind of like a better
version of what happened to Lex Luthor
almost I thought you and McGregor was
excellent he's not exactly scary in the
film which I could see being an issue
kind of more of the threatening sadistic
elements of went more to Chris Messina
as Victor Zsasz and him and Ewan
McGregor have great chemistry in the
film but even McGregor regardless even
if he's not scary he is consistently
engaging and while he pretty much steals
every scene he's in he's not necessarily
stealing the spotlight if that makes
sense he's still in the scene with
everyone else and he still helps elevate
the other performers around him yeah
definitely and I mean yeah from what I'm
not a black mask expert I was sitting
there going I feel like I should fear
this guy more than I do but yeah I mean
even McGregor's performance is great and
I feel like any of the Menace that black
mask was missing at least in terms of
the overall movie gets made up for well
with Victor Zsasz who Chris Messina I
thought did a terrific job in that role
I mean I love Anthony Carrigan on the
Gotham show as Victor Zsasz is a totally
different kind of portrayal this is a
much more evil sick twisted sadistic you
meddling yeah every time he's on screen
wrong with this guy and then in terms of
the other birds of prey players my
personal favorite one out of them I'm
gonna butcher name jurnee smollett Bell
she plays Dinah Lance aka Black Canary
in the movie she's wonderful you really
feel the characters history all the
woman in the film are tough badass
ladies but she brings a certain level of
weight to the role that is different
than the other characters I just think
the writing for her was a little bit
better than the other two that's not the
say the writing for the other two were
bad I just was more gravitated towards
her and I think the movie kind of wants
you to gravitate towards her the others
Leah volley ensemble maybe arguably
aside from Rosie Perez she is the one
who you spend the most time with and you
get to know on the most
personal level I feel like she and
Cassandra Cain have some similar
background stuff but yeah especially in
terms of a character you can sympathize
with who's in a bad situation who
doesn't have a lot of power in that
situation what is trying to stick to
some kind of moral code I thought she
did a terrific job and I really liked
the arc that they gave her and Rosie
Perez I thought might be like funny in
the movie she's not a badass the joke
about her is she's like a cop from the
eighties yeah and they really stick to
that but she's not a joke character when
I heard that line I thought they were
gonna do something where they're making
fun of her character for feeling like
she's from the 80s and while they
acknowledge that she's actually probably
the most dramatic of them mary elizabeth
winstead character is Huntress there was
a point in the film where I was thinking
is she gonna be like totally left out of
this film it's a while before you really
get to spend some screen time with her
it wasn't until like the last ten
minutes of her scenes where I finally
started to get a humor behind her
character because there's a couple of
moments in the trailer when you're
seeing them all United all the birds of
prey and Harley Quinn are United at one
point there's a couple of lines that
they get Mary Elizabeth Winstead where
the humored felt off and flat and I was
like wait a minute did they rewrite her
reshoot some stuff because there's some
when she's just being like serious
assassin character she's very believable
and then there were some humorous parts
that didn't really hit the mark for me
but then eventually I was like oh never
mind I get it now you know yeah I think
that's a line everyone will have to ride
a little bit with this film that line
between realistic within the realm of
the world cartoon enos versus cartoon
enos and luckily I think the movie does
a good job of keeping it cartoony within
its limitations but yeah there are a
couple moments there that seem to get
jokey in a way that it wasn't bad but
yeah you could just be like okay as a
joke there yeah there was yeah it was
there was only in the finale actually
when now kind of bothered me because the
rest of the film honestly from beginning
to end I was smiling throughout most of
this movie I was cracking up a lot
because this movie is eccentric it is
wild it is meta and it's got a very
different kind of structure cuz you're
telling this specifically from Harley
Quinn's perspective her unique choice of
how to narrate this tale and sometimes
oh I forget facts so we let's rewind and
back
tract a little bit so with that in mind
what Kathy Ann did working with her
cinematographer especially she's brought
a very vibrant colorful film to life in
the first act there's some minor pacing
issues that I do have because it starts
off very kinetic it starts off very fast
and I'm smiling from ear to ear and then
the movie needs to like it has to it
needs to slow down at some point and
start telling us like what this story is
about and introduce the other characters
because there's the Harley Quinn world
the other characters don't have the same
kind of mindset she has so when you're
cutting to the other characters and you
got to get to know them the movie does
slow down the reason why I say it's a
minor issue because even though at first
I was like okay I need to readjust a
little bit here the scenes are essential
they're all important scenes to keep the
movie moving they're not like we don't
need this cut it out this is boring
there are scenes that need to slow down
for a purpose it reminded me of Deadpool
a bit in the way that it moves around
its story and the way the narration
plays into that it's hard not to talk
about Suicide Squad when you mention
this movie because it does kind of shoot
out of it but I thought that they took
all of the stylistic earmarks and did
the matter here because it has all that
Kinesis and it has this sort of
revolving door of pop songs and stuff
like that but it all feels really
natural and yeah you have Harley Quinn
who is the unreliable narrators we've
been saying a lot but in a very useful
and a very fun way that breaks the movie
up into what feels like comic-book esque
chunks not to say that it's choppy or
anything like that and there's even some
2d animation in here which just took me
back and that made me happy because you
know Harley Quinn came from the cartoon
so I thought that was kind of a nice nod
I love those stylish touches when a
director knows how to do it properly how
they mess around with the texts that are
on screen when the movie decides to
freeze-frame and have a lot of fun with
the visual touches that's putting on
screen to convey some information I
think a lot of people have said that
this is the movie that Suicide Squad
oughta have been yeah I agree with that
but I think it's so much more than that
I don't love it just because it's better
than Suicide Squad and like I wasn't
even really thinking about Suicide Squad
watching this even though there are some
specific mentions this really feels like
its own thing the emotional beats really
do hit you really get time to hang out
with the characters I think the one
comparison I can make a Suicide Squad
you could feel rewrites you can feel
rushed you can feel reshoots and this
movie felt focused despite how
fast-paced it was despite a energetic it
was it felt like it knew exactly what it
wanted to be exactly what it wanted to
do and I had a great time I think the
action in it is some of the best out of
this DC Universe oh yeah I got audible
noises yeah a lot of the theater I mean
it's not as gory as some people might
have made you think it would be but
there are some bone crunching moments of
that make you go yeah and just some
beautiful action shots you know some
beautiful slow-mo some beautiful set
pieces and look like a lot of the actors
really trained a lot for this movie
because there's there's someone take
shots in here and shots where it's
clearly Margot Robbie I don't know they
were like CG at her face onto a stunt
double or whatever I thought it looked
real and looked like it was really the
actors doing it so hell yeah I mean if
they're I'm sure there's some doubles in
the mix but yeah it seemed like they
went out of their way to show and mary
elizabeth winstead i think lately has
been doing this in a lot of her stuff
but yeah that they really threw down on
the training and can fight so that it
makes it that much more believable yeah
the only thing that ever took me out of
a fight sequence was just that thing of
like there are a bunch of dudes in here
I feel like more of them would be
attacking ya especially after watching
some corridor crew stuntmen react videos
that would sometimes look at the other
actor other stunt performers in the
background going there waiting there
filling it and also the actors who
played Cassandra Cain Ellijay basco the
way how she had to balance this child
who grows up in a domestically violent
home with this pickpocket and then
having this like sarcastic sense of
humor to repress at all she's that
character who is learning to trust and I
thought she did an excellent job her and
Margot Robbie have incredible chemistry
in this film that was some of the
highlights of the movie to me was them
hanging out together I won't go into
specifics as to why but then hanging out
together with some of my favorite parts
of this film yeah and I like the way she
played the character and I like the way
the character was written cuz it wasn't
ever too cheeky it was never to like
look at this precocious kid you know it
felt of the world and it felt like the
right size and generally I mean if you
want to talk about like themes
underneath I think it's nice that they
had so many characters who all come from
different backgrounds teaming up I just
noticed that this morning an older
character you've got a younger character
you've got everybody from privilege to
poverty they're all coming together for
a common goal and so if you want to talk
about like feminist steam synth make
everybody mad I thought that was a nice
little sophisticated nugget that the
movie doesn't again go out of its way to
be like hey hey we're doing this well
the characters but even to an external
cent like even with human McGregor's
black mask character they're all about
trying to prove themselves and get out
of someone else's shadow
hey for the most part and you know
primarily with the main female not all
of them but most of them are in the
shadow of a man and they don't say that
they're unlike it's the man the
character whose shadow they're in is of
the man but it feels appropriate and it
doesn't feel like they're in my face
trying to push an agenda and I think the
reason why that's done so well is
because you got a great female director
here yeah writer too and and Margaret I
mean like I don't know exactly the
extent of her involvement
production-wise but she seems like she
has a say and a pretty good sense when
she picks her projects and so I got to
imagine that that's also part of you
know her involvement we're gonna make
this progressive but in a way that feels
integrated and that isn't like a lot of
our blockbusters are now and honestly
every concern that I might have
expressed in those trailer reactions
were all put to rest there are times
where I be concerned of the whole thing
with Harley Quinn saying she's gonna
make a name for herself and break out of
the identity of the Joker and I'm like
when you keep bringing up the Joker I
just reminded of the Joker
weirdly even though that's a prevalent
thing throughout this whole film I
didn't miss the Joker at all no I'm
totally cool and they do a great job
with that too because it starts out
simply enough with just like she's
grieving and she she acts out and then
she just got to deal with that yeah you
don't even miss the Joker throughout it
like his presence is felt enough just
because of how much of a legend he is
yeah I'd love what DC's been doing
they've been on a solid track record
Aquaman Shazam Joker since they've been
really refocusing what they want to do
and taking bold steps with having two DC
movies in a row that are r-rated hell
yeah I love everything they've been
doing I can tell this movie won't be for
everyone very matter of fact there are
some people in the theater who were not
having it yeah there's some people like
us who were clearly in love with
yeah yeah and and I like that that that
shows kind of the bold direction of what
they're doing is that it's not gonna be
for everyone when they're trying to make
something for everyone it wasn't
satisfying most people and now you got
this direction guys did you see birds of
prey what did you think of it did you
like it did you love it leave a comment
down below you want to see it birds of
prey solo movie with just the birds of
prey themselves leave a comment below
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell and thank you
roosterteeth again for all these goodies